turning to the january 6 select
committee former white house aide
cassidy hutchinson is standing by her
explosive testimony this week after
supporters of former president trump
challenged a key revelation in her
remarks and last night one of the trump
white house officials mentioned by
hutchinson was subpoenaed by the
committee scott mcfarland has more from
capitol hill
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god the stunning
revelations from former white house aide
cassidy hutchinson may have put the
former president in greater legal
jeopardy according to panel member jamie
raskin the evidence becomes so
overwhelming
of an attempted political coup complaint
with ar-15 the focus is on hutchinson's
accusation the president knew the crowd
in dc was armed and headed to the
capitol i overheard the president say
something to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away let my people in they
can march the capital from here the
potential charges according to legal
experts obstructing an official
proceeding the certification of the
election an incitement of a riot
according to hutchinson white house
counsel pat cipoloni raised some of
those concerns mr sabloni said something
to the effect of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy we're going to get
charged with every crime imaginable the
committee subpoenaed him wednesday night
writing in a statement that sipoloni
repeatedly raised legal and other
concerns about president trump's
activities on january 6 and in the days
that proceeded meanwhile there's new
pushback against one part of
hutchinson's testimony in which she
testified white house colleague tony
ornato told her of an incident in the
presidential limo in which then
president trump allegedly lunged at a
secret service agent and tried to grab
the steering wheel when his demand to go
to the capitol january 6 was denied
a source close to the secret service
denied that account
hutchinson's lawyer said she stands by
all of the testimony she provided and
the two republican members of the
committee continue to stand by the
investigation both speaking publicly and
very candidly wednesday night to members
of their own party look you are
republicans you're being lied to you're
being lied to and you're being taken
advantage of um you can't be that
gullible let's let's fight to defend our
democracy we have to choose because
republicans cannot both be loyal to
donald trump
and loyal to the constitution
cheney went on to call the former
president a domestic threat in a post
last night trump said the committee
asking to speak to his white house
counsel is setting a terrible precedent
for future presidents
vlad
all right to be continued scott thank
you very much